all right Courtney mm-hmm
Courtney where'd you grow up were you
from originally uh I don't really
normally tell my town but I grew up in
New Mexico
okay good both your parents as a kid in
offense biological mother adopted father
and how was your childhood I was beaten
by my adoptive father ended up on heroin
he used cattle prods belt with wire
sticking out along paddles where it
would leave well bruises
I had five broken ribs in elementary
school from me and kicked down two
flights of stairs but still steel toe
boots did you report this to any did you
mom know about it she did when the
school seen one of the bruises one day
they called cYFD I was removed from
there but the foster home wasn't much
better so your mom stayed married to him
yes and you had your foster home what
happened there for the first week I was
with the nice Mexican couple didn't
speak a whole lot in English but treated
us good from there I was moved and
beaten and passed beaten and passed
being and passed always known as the
problem child so you've had some
terrible luck in the foster system Mary
it's a common story and then you went
out on your own at what age 16
where'd you go I ended up in a city in
Oklahoma nobody wants to really hire a
16 year old not for full-time work it
which is what you need to live so I had
this girl one day she told me all this
quickly quickly you could make money
don't go away the prostitution so you
started doing it at 16 yeah this was on
your own or through someone else um at
first it was on my own didn't really
know anybody but then you know she
introduced me to her pimp and it just
from there
you can't like once you have a pimp
that's it there's some that are better
than others
some don't beat us as much mm-hmm others
will give you a bigger percentage of the
money that you make you know so you can
buy things for yourself but if you don't
make their money or the money that
you're supposed to meet and you're gone
for a certain amount of time you've got
a nasty incoming card I know that's one
girl that got hit in the head with a
sledgehammer because she was gone and
didn't have the right amount of money
for the time she was gone you had more
than one tip it sounds like especially
traveling from state to state
so yeah our drugs are part of your life
crystal meth customer we're using
crystal meth back then to 16 no but as
16
I really wasn't okay with the idea of
prostitution so I was introduced to
crystal meth is kind of a way to numb
the emotions I guess if you don't feel
it can't let it bother you so and that's
where it all started
I've done crystal meth every way you
could possibly think of it eat it snort
it hot rails slam it
they're called booty blasters letting
marries up I've done it every possible
way you could possibly imagine
that's not my face spin shatter my job's
been shattered from who won was a date
got mad you've had some bad experiences
on customers I didn't know that he was
another pimp trying to take me so when I
called mine because I was gone for this
amount of time with no money then he got
not about that so it's been causing
issue between them and I got hit
not doing what I was told feeding
Menasha and how old are you today 26 so
you been in LA how long I've been in LA
since February and are you still dating
guys for money yes
do you work with a temper are you
working on your own so far I've managed
to make it on my own I just know it's
inevitable so I'm gonna have to pick one
eventually you're I'm just gonna be out
there for everybody to beat up and take
the money from what neighborhoods do you
work there we go
I work all the way from Alameda to
Broadway
what's up basically downtown Skid Row
area well there's the valley there's
Long Beach there's Figueroa there as
well I've been to the valley up in the
Long Beach I've been to Santa Monica
down here just I've been to guard guard
dinner there do you know Gardea yeah
Safavid also sound lots of different
areas
did you work them all mm-hmm you've been
arrested before some highway grace of
God I've managed to stay out of jail for
that one I mean I've been arrested on
like taking out paid stay too long and
one spot in the city or whatever but
mm-hmm
I've never been arrested for
prostitution did your children none that
I've ever seen so you had kids but you
gave them off right away or I didn't
make it to pregnancy because of a nasty
full-term
so where where do you see yourself going
from here so you're 26 and you're you've
been on the street for quite a while now
the addictions got to be a tough one to
shake right it is but I've met some I'm
not some interesting people and the
believe it or not I'm at this one thing
that yeah you work for him
but that percentage of your money have
you asked him to he'll set it back in a
savings account late he pimps him for a
little while until they save up the
money that they need to to get out
interesting that's what I said but
prostitution is never going to end so
like he said prostitution is never gonna
end
he's always gonna because you're gonna
be working for him you know he's gonna
take his cut it's not as much as anybody
else's I guarantee that but he's gonna
take his cut because he's helping you
manage your money as well so in the end
and I've met some of the other females
like he'll call him they'll come they'll
be like yeah I used to I used to work
for him there's one girl just graduated
college with her doctorate he's a good
too because one girl just graduated
college with her doctorate working for
him
and she don't work for him anymore and
he's okay with that they're still really
good friends she said if it wasn't for
him she probably would have died out
here that's interesting so are you
living on the street now I am in a tent
mmm no not exactly I just kind of float
around just wing it pretty much in do
you have like regular customers that'll
contact you and you make money with them
I have those and then I don't know I
guess I'm just so used to it that it
takes me five trips to the store just by
packed cigarettes you can't turn down
can't can't turn down my hey
because once you turn one of them down
then word spreads and the money goes
from up here down here and when money
hits down here it's extremely rough more
than you would think on the streets how
much money will you make on a date on a
date on one date yeah I mean it really
just depends on the area I've had one
date as low as 30 and I've had one date
as high as 1500 so it depends on the
person how much money they've got to
spend how much they're willing to spend
what's the craziest thing you've
experienced in your years of doing this
I had this one that wanted me to suck on
his nipples while he jerked off it was
um whoa let me see it was just gross it
was flat-out gross to me but it made me
my money and helped him out so it's all
I mattered sometimes you just got to
stick through it but you haven't had
anything really violent terrible - other
than the broken bones yeah what kind of
stuff has happened I've been kidnapped
I've been beaten I've been
I've been held at gunpoint there's
things that I've been made to do at
gunpoint that I wouldn't wish anybody
else to have to go through but in the
end the choice was either me or them do
you have any friends
I don't really consider anybody my
friend I don't trust anybody especially
down here ever I don't really trust
anybody ever so what do you think would
help you most therapy or housing or
rehab or combination of all three here
honestly I don't know I really don't
know I think it might depend on how bad
we want it anyway I think a lot of it
would depend on how bad you want it yeah
how much you're used to it like when you
have that last five dollars and you're
doing your life the right way are you
going to automatically revert back to it
or are you gonna be able to push past
that breaking point those because when
you're in the prostitution business and
you get down to the last little bit of
money you're like oh no I got a catch
day I got to catch the day I got catch
date never go without money that's rule
number one and you don't have money
you're not doing your job
and then you have to make sure that if
you don't do anything on your period you
better damn well make sure that you're
out there busting your ass the rest of
the three weeks so you have that money
saved up while you're on your period or
your pimp don't give a [ __ ] you better
get your ass out there and do hand jobs
[ __ ] something you better get your
ass out there and make them funny so so
what is your typical day look like you
wake up and and crystal meth you stay up
all night sometimes
okay everybody has to sleep eventually
so typically my think make as much money
as I can without passing out because
when you pass out then that draws
attention because of ambulances and then
cops and you really don't want that
because they get pissed so you make as
much money as you can without drawing
attention and then if you're gonna be up
all night you know you start building a
little tire find a spot take a couple
hits but you better not be there among
five minutes no get your ass back out
there and be finding a date do you dream
about different life sometimes I used to
thank you soon but I don't think it'll
ever happen for me I think that this is
my life and quite possibly all it will
ever be mess up one time wrong hit one
way you're dead
there's a good chance you might there's
a good chance I could end up dead hmm
taming is walking out this door
if that people die every date in the
street then it's nothing
walk my dead bodies all the time before
people here realize they're dead and
they don't even face me where I'm like
that sucks that's the kind of life it is
your mom and stepdad are still alive
father no mother I'm not sure I don't
stay in contact with her you haven't
talked to her
oh don't have anything savory so no
family no friends
pretty much
just
trying to give eye
trying to have a that's like I can for
somebody like me it's kind of hard to
have a boyfriend whenever all you do is
have sex for money so then whenever they
want to have sex you like and uh kind of
makes them feel some type of way so have
you been in love before
yeah birth mistake my he
you see me flip out I was high and
tweaking he tried to restraining I gave
him no choice but to hit me but but
because I pushed him to that point he
walked away it would never talk to me
that's whenever you learn you can't have
both worlds you can't have a boyfriend
and do this you can't do this and have
any expect any expectancy and normal
life
there isn't one cuz the second somebody
finds out what you do they see you
completely differently than the person
think you knew you to be that one little
thing changes everything all of a sudden
they don't want to hang out with you
because they don't know if they can
trust their boyfriend around you or and
it's not even like that
but that's worldview on it so it's how
it goes kind of hard to keep friends
that way too
do you see the connection between what
happened to you as a as a young girl and
in the situation you're in today yes
it's almost like you're here what you
believe you deserve is set at that young
age I think it's so much we you think
you deserve because obviously I went
around hey it 16 if I thought I deserved
that but just because you think you can
make it on your own at such a young age
you can't
so all it did is keep the cycle going
because I never knew anything better
than what I've got so I mean it's life
but sometimes I Satan wonder like if I
had come from a good family you know or
have been raised right or had you know
finished high school or went to college
or you know had the family like the good
side of family life I wonder if I'd
actually have this kind of life I don't
I mean I guess it's possible but I
really don't see it and you come from a
good family
why are you gonna make stupid decisions
not so much that running away was stupid
because I was getting beaten but it and
then sometimes you sit there and you
dream like oh maybe one day I'll meet
one of these dates and they're just
gonna be you know the guy that gets me
the [ __ ] out of here silly
all right Courtney thank you so much for
sharing your story and I hope you figure
out a way off the streets thanks thank
you very much okay